APARNA SINHA: This is one
of my favorite audiences
I feel that at KubeCon,
you get a mix of folks that
are interested in the
high level and also
really want to know the details
and play with the technology.
So today, we have an agenda
that's tailored just for you.
I'm Aparna Sinha.
I lead product for Kubernetes,
GKE, and our Anthos product.
Today, we're going to talk about
how you can use Google Cloud
technologies to accelerate
your journey towards enterprise
transformation.
Google Cloud has had
outstanding success
in helping companies of all
sizes really modernize and move
to the cloud.
And every industry today
is the digital industry.
We're seeing technology
transform entire sectors
and change the basis
for competition.
And I think we see it all
in our daily lives, too.
If you think about how
you got here today,
whether you use a taxi service,
how you educate your children,
how you buy your
groceries, all of that
has really changed in
the last five years.
On a personal note, my
children's school curriculum
actually runs on Google Cloud.
And so I can say from experience
that Google Cloud is really
leading this transformation.
And it's not just
for small companies.
It's in companies that
are hundreds of years old
that are looking to
transform their industry.
And how do we do this?
We do this through
cutting edge technology.
In Google Cloud, in
particular, technology
that enables applications
that are highly personal that
have intelligence that are agile
that are efficient and that
give you access.
So if you're on
an IT team today,
what does this mean for you?
I think many of you in the
audience already experienced
this.
But when I look at the
role of the IT team
from five years ago to
today, it has really changed.
It used to be that IT was
responsible for cost reduction.
And the funny thing
is that IT is still
responsible for cost reduction.
But on top of that, you're also
responsible for contributing
to the top line.
You're responsible for
ensuring faster time
to market and agility.
And that's not
easy because you've
got to do more with less.
And you've got to make sure
that you get to that agility
without compromising security.
So when I talk to
CIOs today, they say,
in order to enable
true speed to market,
I have to have an
agile platform.
And I have two questions
associated with that.
Number one, how do I
either build this platform
or get this platform?
Should I buy something off the
shelf that's enterprise ready?
Or should I build
it from scratch
and continuously maintain it?
And the second question is,
how do I balance my investment
in existing systems or systems
on-prem and modernizing
those systems, versus what
I'm using in the cloud?
Those are the two most
pressing questions that I hear.
And actually, the answer to
these two questions is related.
In our view, you've got
to pick a platform that
is consistent that
actually runs both on-prem,
as well as in public cloud,
and, in fact, in multiple public
clouds.
That's the reality of today.
And so in choosing
this platform,
the reason that's
important is because it
allows you to maximize the
investment in your talent.
So you don't have to retrain
your engineers in every cloud
environment.
And ultimately, building
this platform yourself
is not a great idea,
because it takes
a lot of top talented engineers
to build such a thing.
Those engineers could be
better utilized actually
contributing to business
differentiating capability.
This is why earlier this year,
Google Cloud introduced Anthos.
Anthos is a
modernization platform.
It's meant for you to develop
applications and run them
anywhere.
And it's a platform
that's very flexible.
It can run in your
on-prem environment.
It can run in Google Cloud.
It can run in other clouds.
And it can also run at the
edge in your branch locations,
in retail stores,
even in stadiums.
What's unique about
Anthos is three things.
Number one, that
it's software-based.
Most people that I
talked to already
have quite a bit of hardware.
They've, perhaps,
chosen a hardware
vendor that they're
working with.
They've got contracts in place.
Or in some of the
edge locations,
there's a lot of constraint in
terms of what the footprint is.
So having a software
platform means
that you have flexibility.
You can purchase new
hardware if you choose to.
Or you can try and reuse
what you already have.
The second unique capability is
that it's built on open source.
It's open, but it's opinionated.
And the opinionation is
actually really important.
It means that,
with Anthos, we're
building in all that Google has
learned about how to run an SRE
function, how to manage
applications at scale, how
to do container management.
That's part of the platform.
Open means that it's portable.
But it's not so hard to manage.
And then, lastly, it
abstracts the infrastructure
so that your folks can actually
focus on business innovation.
And that last part is
something that we learned
from our experience with GKE.
I think many of the folks in
the crowd today have used GKE.
Perhaps we can have a
show of hands how many?
You've used GKE.
Yeah, about 80% of the audience.
That's quite good.
So GKE was introduced five
years ago, actually in November.
We're celebrating the
fifth birthday of GKE.
And it has seen
incredible success.
You can see we've
got a lot of users
across industries
and at various sizes.
It's top-rated by analysts.
And it's been
acknowledged by customers.
I think the most
important thing here
has been the success
that GKE has enabled
for its customers and
the type of applications
that they've built.
For example, eBay
has built a shop bot
that enables personalized
shopping on their mobile app.
Pizza Hut enables
faster delivery
of pizzas to you
during Super Bowl
and also during any regular day.
But these are things
that, as a product lead,
it's really heartwarming to see
our customers implement changes
that affect our lives every day.
And why is that possible?
That's possible, because
even though they're
using Kubernetes,
they're not actually
managing the Kubernetes.
GKE is taking away
a lot of the toil so
that they can focus on building
new experiences for their end
users.
That's the key learning.
How did we do this?
We did this actually by
abstracting the infrastructure
and automating more and more
capabilities over the last five
years.
We started by managing
the control plane
and then providing auto
repair, auto scaling, and auto
management of the nodes.
And then we saw
that actually was
really helpful to our users.
So then we added
additional capabilities,
like auto scaling of GPUs.
And the result was that machine
learning workloads took off
on GKE.
So as we add more automation,
we see more and more usage.
We've now added
four-way autoscaling.
So you can vertically
autoscale your pods.
You can also
autoprovision, so you
don't have to worry about the
efficiency of your cluster.
It automatically takes
care to make sure
that you're running in
the most efficient manner.
And we're not stopping there.
This list on the
left-hand side is just
the number of new capabilities
added to GKE in the last two
months.
Here you see that we're
making the platform more
secure through container
native networking.
We're making it more
reliable, especially upgrades.
I think earlier today someone
mentioned, hey, what are we
doing to improve upgrades?
We're making them more reliable
through a number of features--
one of which is
called surge upgrades.
Another capability
is release channels,
which allows you to choose
your level of innovation-- how
much of a cutting
edge release you
want to use versus stability.
And then in terms
of agility, we've
been adding many more workloads.
Today, 60% of workloads
on GKE are staple.
That's databases
and batch workloads.
And we're adding
support for Windows,
which is moving to beta this
week, and also batch workloads.
So what we learned
from this experience
is that it's truly important
to give users choice.
But that choice should come
with opinionation and management
in order to be adoptable.
That's the foundation on
which Anthos is building.
Anthos is taking that
GKE core and bringing it
to the on-prem environment,
as well as to other clouds.
But it's very much tailored
towards the enterprise
and the CIO.
We take the managed platform,
and we add several layers
on top.
First of all, in an
enterprising environment,
you need centralized policy
and configuration management.
So that's a key element.
It's at the heart of the
Anthos control plane.
Secondly, with many
services across environments
in your cloud, you need
service management.
And that's something that comes
out of the box with Anthos.
And then, most
importantly, in order
to make the
developers productive,
you need a seamless
developer experience.
And that's something
that we're enabling
with Cloud Run on Anthos.
So I'm going to try and
give you a whirlwind tour
of the capabilities of Anthos.
But the whole day is devoted to
going through these in detail.
So this will just
be a quick one.
Here, I'm going to cover five
unique aspects of the platform.
First, how do you get started?
Is it a forklift?
Or is it easy to
get started with?
Second, now that
you've started with it,
how do you make sure
that it's secure?
Third, how can you make
those developers productive?
Fourth, what about your
legacy applications?
And then, lastly, how
do you operate at scale?
So let's get into it.
Anthos is not a rip
and replace platform.
No matter where you
are in your journey,
you can get started easily.
And to enable that, we have
this capability so you can bring
your own clusters to Anthos.
And we're going to
demo that later today.
But it's already in beta.
And many customers are using it.
What that means is that,
if you have a Kubernetes
cluster somewhere-- and most
enterprises have Kubernetes
somewhere at this point.
If it's a conformant cluster,
you can connect it up
to the Anthos control plane.
And you can get a
single pane of glass
for visibility, as well as
for workload management.
If you don't have a cluster,
as many of you know,
it's easy to get
started with GKE.
You can start a cluster
in less than 5 minutes.
And then it's part of
the Anthos control plane.
Or you can use GKE on-prem,
our Anthos on-prem offering,
and bring that to the cloud.
If you have no containerized
applications at all--
we'll talk about later today--
you can migrate existing
VM-based applications
into Anthos as well.
So there are many ways
to getting started.
And it doesn't have to be a
lift and shift or a forklift.
Second, once you get
started, how do you make sure
that the environment is secure?
Anthos has a number of
capabilities built in
to ensure security by default.
There's actually a long list.
But some of the ones that
I'd like to cover and show
in this animated GIF--
Anthos brings the ability
to have consistent security
and configuration enabled
from a single source of truth.
Typically this is a Git repo.
You set your policies
in the Git repo.
And these are policies
that could be security
policies related to your mesh.
They could be RBAC policies
related to Kubernetes or quota
policies.
And from the single
source of truth,
these policies are distributed
to all of the enrolled clusters
and then enforced.
What this GIF shows is an
Anthos policy controller.
This controller texts
all of the access
to any API in your
cluster and make sure
that it complies with
the enterprise policies
that you've set.
That's just one of the controls.
There's also security controls
built into the service mesh.
And then, lastly, Anthos comes
with binary authorization,
which enables you to
define security checks
upstream in the
development process,
making sure that only validated
verified images are integrated
into your building
release process.
Security is not just
for security's sake.
Security is what actually
enables development
to go faster because it
doesn't stand in the way.
So once you've made
a secure environment,
and you've brought your
environment into Anthos,
then comes the most
important task,
which is building applications.
So how do we make that easier?
There's two ways.
First, Anthos comes with
a Kubernetes application
marketplace.
That makes it really easy
to procure applications that
are already tested and
available from both first party
and third-party providers.
This GIF is showing
you CloudBees.
If you want to deploy
CloudBees, it's
actually a single
click deployment
from the Anthos marketplace.
And you can choose which
cluster you want to deploy to.
It can be any of the
clusters that are enrolled,
including on-prem clusters
or clusters in other clouds.
And this service is supported
by the partner-- in this case,
CloudBees-- and comes
with integrated billing
from Google Cloud.
This is, of course, if you want
to reuse existing services.
What about the most
important piece,
which is your own services that
your developers will build?
And that's where the easy
application development
experience of Anthos
and Cloud Run comes in.
So this is showing you how
you can take a container image
and deploy it into
a cluster and have
an internet-exposed application
in less than a minute.
It's an extremely
simple user experience.
It works for clusters
in Google Cloud.
It also works now
for clusters on-prem.
The fourth aspect-- you've got
your cloud native applications.
But what about your
legacy applications?
And that's where Migrate
for Anthos comes in.
This is actually
brand new technology.
It's quite differentiated.
It doesn't exist anywhere else.
And what it does is it takes
existing monolithic workloads
that are residing in VMs.
They could be in VMware VMs.
Or they could be in
VMs in another cloud.
And it automatically
migrates those applications
into a StatefulSet in
Kubernetes and brings it
into the Anthos environment.
There are certain
benefits of doing this.
It's not a magic solution.
It doesn't get you
a microservices.
It's still a monolith.
But the benefits of
doing this is that one,
it's a lot easier to get in.
And secondly, it
actually does give you
the advantages of bin packing.
So you get a more
efficient environment
where you're using your monolith
in a more effective way.
Usually, the efficiency is
from such a migration actually
pay for the migration itself.
And finally, once you have
these applications into Anthos,
how do you manage them at scale?
That's the fifth part.
And that is what we enable
with service management--
Anthos Service Management.
This is really built
upon the best practices
that we found within Google
through our SRE function.
The service graph essentially
is an at-a-glance view
of all the services
in your environment.
It gives you a
hierarchical picture
where you can drill
down into the resources.
And you can see
the relationships
between the services.
You can see the traffic
flow between the services
and monitor various important
metrics, like the latency.
And you can set SLOs
on those metrics
to see when there are violations
and also policies to remediate.
These are some of
the best practices
that we have learned
through management
of many microservices
in our environment.
And we found that the
largest customers in GKE
have, in fact,
many, many services.
And this becomes a
necessity at that point.
So those are the five kind
of core pillars of Anthos
that we're going to walk
through in detail today.
Each of the sessions
later today will go in
and show you the
technology, show you
what the capabilities are in
the form of an actual demo.
And you'll have a chance
to ask the engineering
team and the product team
questions afterwards.
In order to implement
a transformation
in an enterprise, we
found that it's not
enough to just cater to
the needs of developers
or to the needs of
the platform team.
That's why Anthos has so
many different capabilities--
something that caters to each
role in the organization.
For the platform engineering
team, easy tools to help them
manage the operations
environment.
For the developers,
integration with their IDEs
and the ability to choose
from the marketplace
or build an application
in a serverless fashion.
For service operators, all the
goodness of the SRE tooling.
And then, of course, for
security and compliance,
built-in capability.
And we're finding that
our customers are finding
a lot of value from this.
Some of our financial
services customers
are improving their
agility by 13x.
We've also found in the most
traditional of industries,
a company, like Airbus,
being able to use
serverless technology in their
on-prem and cloud environment.
This is truly
revolutionizing their work.
And in order to enable
it, we've got an ecosystem
of partners for Anthos.
At different layers
in the marketplace,
we have technology partners.
Increasingly more and more
enterprise applications
are being containerized and made
available in the marketplace
for you to use directly.
In terms of platform
partners, Cisco, HP, and Dell
have provided reference
architectures.
Should you want to
buy new hardware,
you can couple that with Anthos.
And then several of
our service partners--
some of whom are
even here today--
are available to assist
with the migration process.
Anthos is really enabling
new business opportunities.
You saw several examples today.
In financial services, in
retail and health sciences,
customers are using
these capabilities
to bring new experiences.
HSBC, for example, is enabling
a transformation in banking
to reach their
customers more easily.
In retail and commerce,
particularly with the edge,
you're seeing much
more innovation
happening with
the retail season.
And then, lastly
in health care, we
have companies that are using
AI to improve the drug discovery
process.
The question is really,
what will all of you
do with this platform?
And I think that is what
we hope to inspire today
through the discussion.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]